uh so i just found out from your
directors amanda
that the author of the book that this
movie is based on had you in mind
when she was writing your character so
does it feel like you were meant to play
this role
oh yeah that was bananas when i found
that out also
there are a lot of weird things that
happened during this movie i know um
that guy was the the what
whatever story was based on without
giving too much away
uh somebody in real life was um
convicted of of some some stuff
while we were shooting so i i think
there's a lot of weird stuff happening
while we were shooting this movie i mean
it's in the hudson valley
what was he convicted or was he released
one of the other i remember convicted
was he committed he wasn't really all
right it's pretty dark again
sorry we should with some half giving
spoilers it's tantalizing isn't it
no no it's great it's great teasers um
james you uh you thoroughly creep me out
in this movie not gonna lie you did a
great job
like yeah what was it like for you kind
of getting into the headspace of someone
who
has a lot of layers i mean great that's
kind of what we do
what we do this for um it was really
i mean he he's he's unfortunately the
kind of guy
who still does sort of creep around and
and we know these
nasty men who you know feel entitled to
her life which
they they feel like do they deserve and
therefore their wife or people around
them should kind of
give them that life and live in the
relation to them and
these narcissists creep around society
and they unfortunately will sometimes a
lot of power and so
um george is yeah he's one of those
one of those people but um yeah he was
beautifully drawn and the relationship
between him and
catherine was kind of the draw for us
both i think because
you know it was it was heartbreaking and
and um
and tragic and yet really sophisticated
and it's kind of intelligent so we uh
yeah we had a lot of fun just dissecting
that dysfunctional
relationship amanda did you say that
james freaked out on set too
yeah he's just really um off-putting
i'm kidding i don't see that
no we actually had the best time i've
never laughed
that much shooting movie in my life like
my body missed
it you know we had such a good group of
people
but that's what you have to do when
you're shooting something that's very
heavy at times
and also supernatural it's like there's
like a physical challenge there i mean
the end of the move well anyway i'm not
sorry
difficult not to give it away but um
there's just a lot of
physical stuff that ends up happening
especially between the two of us
and you've gotta off offset that with
some kind of levity
yeah sorry
like there were certain scenes which
really required us to go
but particularly before it got really
crazy where this fact this the
relationship really started to kind of
unwind in a way which we can all relate
to you know like arguments and
and until it got really physically
physically violent and um you have to
trust your
kind of playing partner your tennis
player um and amanda's
uh yeah just the best she kind of she
makes it we had a lot of fun but it was
so
those scenes were really really um fun
to bat
back and forth yeah well you guys had
such great chemistry
and the supernatural elements were so
good in this honestly i'm such a big fan
of horror films and this movie really
creeped me out so congratulations
yeah i know it was fantastic guys thank
you